[Music]
thanks a lot you know it's funny because
I was just noticing in I mean I've
noticed it a million times in your
performances and in that clip there you
have such an inch you're very
intimidating look I'm sure you've heard
that before you know you're just you're
you you just have this well not now now
you're going it's so funny it's like if
it didn't look at you like I do I mean
serious I mean like and and I think for
that reason people gravitate towards
giving you these these intense roles
don't you it's true yeah do you ever
think you're not doing it now I'm seeing
now that in real life you're kind of a
goofy you know you're like okay yeah
we're ready to go and action and then
you're just like do you ever think did
you Jarrett is there a part of you that
wants to do a you know a really silly
comedy like a Herbie the lovebug remake
or absolutely but because people don't
often think of me for it you know it's
like you're gonna bend over backwards to
make anyone think you can do it so
sometimes it doesn't quite make sense
right and they're you know particularly
when they're casting movies they're
pretty literal about he's a funny guy
he's not a funny guy they aren't every
difference right he's done that before
so what's just exactly just get him for
that but in the theatre I do stuff
that's comic I think and also there's
different kinds of comedy I mean
something like I don't know whether you
remember wild at heart but that turn as
Bobby Perrault is is its high comedy is
rising right well let's talk about you
you have a theater group right down in
Soho the Wooster group right and am i
pronouncing it right yeah okay like the
street just like the street okay you
have this you have this theater group
down there and I've actually seen you
around that part of town a lot I never
say hi I'm very shy but but I've noticed
that I but I've noticed that that's a
part of town where there are a lot of
clubs a lot of parties going on a lot of
partiers is that does that bother you do
they ever you know when you're walking
around your club is that ever a problem
if they're right next to your theater
all those clubs it's probably good for
the theater I mean sometimes it's a
little crowded down there and I've been
down there for almost 25 years it's
changed a lot
mm-hmm you know you get
drunk people hanging out at 4 o'clock in
the morning you know pissing on your
stoop that sort of thing you're so
easygoing
laughs occasionally a guy comes to my
theater pisses on the front of it but
what are you gonna do have you actually
really have you actually caught someone
doing that absolutely I mean one time I
remember seeing a guy pissing right on
my stoop and they said hey what are you
doing and they looked at me you know
making a mess of himself and he said I
can't help it I'm from New Jersey
[Laughter]
you know whether he was making the
excuse because he couldn't hold it until
he got home yeah cuz there are no
bathrooms here in the city yeah right
it's on their license plate now yeah the
there of course in this city there are a
lot of an especially downtown there's a
it's a serious problem there a lot of
homeless people walk them around and do
you some people take some people are
afraid to talk to them in this city
actually I think you're kind of forced
to you know you have to interact with
them which i think is kind of good have
you found that to be well yeah there's
homeless people down in Soho because I
think it's a safe place for them to
sleep no one seems to bother them and
actually near the theater I've known
like I can think of three people in
particular that I've seen they've lived
on the street for years and right I have
a relationship with them and they give
me advice you know career advice and
serious self advice young I remember one
night coming home quite late and one of
these guys says to me hey will you guys
start taking care of yourself yet you
gotta take that advice box right I'm
worried about you
well it's a American Psycho this is a
very it was very controversial book when
it came out right and so it's it's kind
of gutsy to say okay I want to be in
this film because when the book came out
it polarized people there were people
that loved it and there were people that
were absolutely incensed by it
yeah were you at all worried about
taking on the movie role or not real mm
no you know I've known the director for
a little while she did a movie called I
shot Andy Warhol right found it was a
great script I liked the book mm-hmm
I was just you know happy to be a part
of it I don't have a big role in it but
I just like the whole project so in and
I think I like it very much it's very
very understated and funny and dark at
the same time right it blends the two
which is very hard to do I would imagine
it is American Psycho it opens next
Friday but you can see it sooner at a
benefit screening for the Worcester
here in New York City next Wednesday
April 12th and that's benefiting your
theater right in and also there's a
party afterwards where John Kayla's
gonna be performing oh that sounds good
yeah can I come to that and then piss on
your stoop after it just seems like the
thing to do now
all right well Willem thank you very
much continued success welcome to fall
everybody no doubt is coming out